apply the farther galaxies are away the
faster they're moving away and is it
also the case that it's the red shift
explains the fact that the night sky is
primarily black instead of lit up yeah
the latter question is related to
something called olber's Paradox which
is that in an infinite Universe
populated with an infinite number of
objects stars in this case no matter
where you were in that Universe you
would look out and your eye your line of
sight would terminate on the star's
surface somewhere they might be really
far away but eventually your eye would
come to rest on a star so that would
mean that it's a paradox that our night
sky we have during the day we see just
one star but even at night we don't see
any or the night Sky's intensity is
nowhere near as close as the surface of
the Sun let alone the infinite intensity
of an infinite number of suns and it's
as if you were in a forest imagine a
beautiful boreal forest and it's
effectively infinite the trees are a
finite width but they're and they're
spaced at some distance away from you
but there's an infinite number of trees
and as you scan the around your local
Horizon all you would see is bark all
you would see are the trunks of these
trees that's olber's Paradox for trees
and what you're bringing up is this
notion that was interestingly really
encountered and and proposed and even a
solution perhaps by Edgar Allan Poe he
conjectured this idea that it's kind of
strange that we we're told we live in an
infinite universe that even the Milky
Way galaxy could be infinite in size we
didn't know back then in the 19th
century and so it began to be a paradox
now the resolution of that Paradox as
you're pointing out is several fold one
is that the condition for the night sky
to not be dark is that the universe is
infinitely old that the universe is
infinitely big and that universe is
static these stars are not moving in
that simple-minded Paradox as the trees
are not moving in the Albers Paradox
analogy for trees those trees are
stationary the forest is infinite and
the light has had enough time to travel
to your eyes because the universe is
infinitely old so if any one of those
three
propositions is falsified then you can
demolish the Paradox as a paradox so the
resolution interestingly enough comes
down to all three of those are false it
would have been sufficient to falsify
one or of those three propositions the
universe is infinitely old infinitely
big and static but we actually know now
that the Universe isn't any one of those
three at least the universe that we can
observe